- [Both] We accidentally became a meme,
and this is that story.
- My name is Quenlin Blackwell.
I go by Quen Blackwell on the internet.
- (sings) It's Ms. Juicy, baby.
And you might also know me from this meme.
- That's me, yeah.
Do y'all want the long
story or the short story?
(winding up noise)
(screams)
Okay, so I became a really big personality
on Vine and Twitter.
Would anyone like some stew?
16 is a young age.
I was still finding myself as a teenager,
I was experimenting, doing crazy things,
while trying to juggle, like,
be an internet personality,
horrible thing to do.
If you're a teenager on
social media, get the fuck off
and go, you know, make a mistakes
without the world seeing.
But I didn't.
So my family independently
owns a skincare company
and wanted to like
capitalize all my audience
on the internet.
And I was like, "Oh cool, you bet."
So it (laughs) it didn't work.
There was the main tweet of
me like promoting the like,
"Hey guys, I have the skincare
brands, like coming up."
My parents were like, "Can
you post this product?
I'm like, "Yep."
Let me just do a little bit of face.
You know like, you know how Proactive
does like the skin thing really like just
make the skin look extra perfect?
I can't fucking do that from my house.
So I was like, yeah, let
me just get this all good.
I'm like posting it, like, eh.
And then I wake up the next morning
and it has so many fucking
retweets, like 200,000 retweets.
I'm like, oh yes, like.
But everyone was making fun of me.
People were like, this is a scam.
She's looks fake in her pictures.
The skincare actually worked
and it's my family skincare bread.
And then there was a tweet
where someone asked me
about the product and I'm in
the car with my friends like,
"Yeah, let's go to our (indistinct)."
Like trying to deal with
like this internet the shit
at the same time and
respond to the wrong tweet,
and they're like, "What
will this do to my skin?"
And I'm like ingredients from
around the world will like
it literally made no sense.
I was tweaked out of my mind tweeting that
but I couldn't come out and say that
because I was a child.
And I didn't even put out the product
because I knew in my heart,
if these people think
I'm like evil and scamming,
I'm not going to put it out.
And I didn't hear the end of
it for like two years after.
Every time I would tweet
it would be like quotes
(indistinct).
It'd be like ingredients
from around the world.
It was the sentence I tweeted
when I was tweaked out
of my mind.
So then the internet hated
me, very, very badly.
And I became extremely anorexic.
This is like, it's so delusional.
But I thought all these
people don't fucking like me.
Maybe they'll like me if I'm skinny.
That's what my brain told me.
I've suffered with eating
disorder in the past.
But it just like, re-triggered it, like.
During that time I was
delirious and delusional.
It happens when your brain
isn't getting nutrients.
I went on a car drive,
because that's what I usually
did when I felt overwhelmed.
And I was like, "Hmm, I think
today I'm going to drive
into oncoming traffic because
everyone fucking hates me
and I hate me too."
And then something in the inside of me
told me not to do that,
but I was just sobbing and sobbing.
And then I went home and
I don't know what wire
in my brain got singed the fuck
off because of the internet,
but I think to record it.
Put up the camera, I'm like,
my mom always tells me,
"Scream it out, scream it out."
So then I just do that exactly.
And I'm like (screams).
No, I'm still sad. It didn't work.
People do what Twitter people do,
after I posted that video
and they quote tweeted it
and related it to themselves.
And then like a year later.
- [both sing] Ms. Juicy, baby.
- (laughs) And I love Ms. Juicy so much.
- I am Juicy and you just might know me
from Little Women: Atlanta.
(upbeat music plays)
Born and raised in Corsicana, Texas.
Always been in entertainment.
Growing up as a little kid,
because I was different
from an average size person,
they wanted to stare,
so I had to give them
a reason to stare.
I've never been shy, but
I have the gift to gab.
So why not get paid to
do what you love to do?
I think I was born a
Dallas cowboy fan, honey.
It runs through my blood.
As a matter of fact
if I cut myself right
now, you will not see red.
You will see blue and silver.
So I got to watch my Cowboys.
It doesn't matter where I am.
I love football parties,
but when I'm watching
mu Dallas Cowboys, I
need full concentration.
Look at this meme.
Baby, I was in deep though.
I don't need no company
when it comes to my Cowboys.
I have to feel myself because I go live,
so I can interact with my fans
while I'm watching a game.
Believe it or not some
of you guys was there
when this meme happened
because I was on live talking to you.
Oh my God.
Sometimes when the Cowboys
playing, oh, they get me on edge.
They had got tackled.
One of them had got tackled.
So I was very concerned because
we needed to win that game.
And honey, look what done happen. A meme.
After this meme went viral,
I was just on the internet
and somebody sent it to me and they say,
"Girl, look at you."
And you know what? I say,
"They done did it again."
- So the first instance
I've seen the two pictures
being brought together is from
this Twitter user in Mexico.
- This meme is everywhere.
- It's artwork, I've seen
it used for hospital ads
in like Colombia.
Oh, I saw me in someone's homework.
I was explaining a math problem.
Even though I did want
to kill myself that day
it turned into such a cool thing.
- I would love to meet
the young lady by the name
of Quinn because honey,
you have changed my life.
Thank you.
Thank you Quinn.
I really appreciate it.
- Ms. Juicy, before our meme
existed with us together
I loved you.
I knew you and I would love
to meet you in real life.
After this whole pandemic ends.
Humans are imperfect and
we all have struggles
and if you have an eating disorder,
it's a really common issue.
It's the highest mortality
rate of any mental disorders.
So I would say take it seriously.
Reach out to someone.
You'll feel 10 times better
healthy than you will skinny
and cold and frail and dying.
- I would say anybody. that's
going through something,
always think of the positive,
make any negative situation
turn it into a positive situation.
That's the way I go with my life.
- This is the best thing
that could ever exist.
And I'm so grateful for it all.
So cool.
It's so cool.
Like my kids are gonna be
like, "Mom, what did you do?"
I was like, "Be a cool-ass bitch."
That's all your mom did.
Your mom was a meme.
(trumpet music plays)
(continues to play)